[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the most
prominent mentors in harry potter's life
in order of most influential and
greatest importance got any guesses on
who makes this list i'm sure you do
right well let's get to it then number
five professor minerva mcgonagall as far
as mentors go i would say that
mcgonagall was the least influential in
harry's life in fact i dare say some may
disagree that she was a mentor to him at
all however i would argue that by merely
being the head of gryffindor house
during harry's time at hogwarts she was
in a position of mentorship for just
about any student who had been sorted
there which of course included mr potter
what's more for harry in particular she
was of course present the night lily and
james potter were murdered helping
decide where the newly orphaned infant
harry should be sent you may recall that
she was against dumbledore's decision to
place harry with the dursley family and
argued that he should remain with
wizarding kind instead now this may not
necessarily make mcgonagall a mentor as
it's true that harry was no more than a
year old at the time and did not grow up
to remember these events
but it would have remained a vivid
memory for minerva perhaps influencing
her choices to support harry more than
the average student when he inevitably
ended up attending hogwarts i think a
perfect example of this was when
professor mcgonagall discovered harry
flying a broomstick around school
property without permission and instead
of punishing him she recruited him as
gryffindor's new seeker for the house
quidditch team put quite simply without
minerva's interference and influence
harry may never have tried out for the
quidditch team or at the very least not
in his first year at school this would
have altered a great deal for harry and
his hogwarts experience for it was on
the quidditch pitch that we saw harry
develop more confidence it's also where
he got to know several of his fellow
gryffindors exposing him to more
friendships than he may have had if he
just kept to himself
finally a golden snitch the small
charmed ball that seekers are tasked
with catching during a quidditch match
and played an incredibly important role
in hiding and revealing one of the
deathly hallows the resurrection stone
to harry in the last installment of the
series for these reasons minerva
mcgonagall is my pick for harry's fifth
most important mentor number four
professor severus snape
while severus snape may have been at
odds with harry for the majority of the
boy's time at hogwarts i think it's
pretty hard to deny that he provided
harry with vital instruction on at least
a couple subjects
to start with snape was the professor
who attempted to teach harry oclamancy
the magical skill of being able to close
one's mind to another which all wizards
attempt to perform legitimacy and true
these lessons were nothing short of
hostile and according to dumbledore a
fiasco however simply by trying to teach
harry this difficult skill he was
mentoring the boy's development of magic
as the sessions were private individual
lessons created specifically for harry
to help him learn how to close his mind
to voldemort's thoughts and influence in
addition to the occlumency lessons in
the half blood prince harry also learned
a great deal from snape's old potions
textbook which contained all of
severus's notes transcribed in the
columns again i suppose you could argue
that this was not an act of mentorship
as it was likely a coincidence that
harry ended up with this particular
second-hand book and it may well have
been just that
but there was a moment between harry and
snape when severus questions harry about
the textbook saying
this is your copy of advanced potion
making is it potter
yes said harry still breathing hard
you're quite sure of that are you potter
yes said harry with a touch more
defiance snape clearly recognized the
book as his as he revealed later in the
half-blood prince and yet he didn't
expose harry for pretty much cheating
his way through potions meaning that he
knew his notes were helping harry
succeed in this subject considering this
mentor mentee arrangement was not
particularly favorable for either snape
or harry with severus finding harry
arrogant like his father the wizard who
had bullied him in school and inevitably
married the witch he loved and harry
believing snape to be inherently evil
and jealous of his father i think it's
safe to call this a begrudged mentorship
but even though neither wizard was
especially fond of teaching or learning
from the other harry did in fact learn a
great deal from snape putting him at
number 4 on today's list after all we
don't always have to like our mentors do
we number 3. rubius hagrid
hagrid may not have been a mentor to
harry in an academic way since he
himself was expelled before he could
graduate from hogwarts however rubius
was without a doubt one of the most
positive figures in harry's life
after all hagrid was the one who came
for harry after he'd been accepted to
hogwarts despite the dursleys refusing
to allow harry to attend hagrid simply
wouldn't take no for an answer and
showed great strength of character in
helping harry leave for school he was
also the first person to ever give harry
a birthday cake at least that harry
could remember and hagrid's kindness
compassion and protective instincts
towards harry never faltered from there
he was the first person to tell harry
who he really was and how his parents
had died
he introduced harry to diagon alley in
the wizarding world as a whole
hagrid even gave harry his beloved owl
hedwig as a gift throughout harry's time
at hogwarts he could always count on
hagrid visiting his cabin on the school
grounds to have little chats and ask for
advice even when hagrid was meant to
keep information from harry or didn't
know the answer to something he was
always kind and cared a great deal for
our dear boy and so by setting such a
great example for harry hagrid is my
pick for harry's third most important
mentor number two sirius black
sirius black's role as one of harry's
most influential mentors is indisputable
as james potter's best friend who
sacrificed his freedom to confront peter
pettigrew the wizard who betrayed
harry's parents to lord voldemort his
love for the potter family was quite
obvious and his interest in becoming
harry's guardian and mentor was evident
almost immediately once he revealed his
true intentions in the prisoner of
azkaban from harry's perspective sirius
was the guardian he had always wanted
despite his criminal record which of
course was not a reflection of true
events he was a substantial improvement
from the dursleys who verbally attacked
him and never wished to discuss his
parents sirius on the other hand cared
deeply for harry instantly and had a
direct connection to his parents whom he
would speak freely about the harry
sirius represented more than a mentor he
was the father he had never had before
his death ceres would check in on harry
through letters in the magical
fireplaces within hogwarts he even
risked his freedom to return to england
and hide out in a cave near the school
to ensure harry's safety as a wizard
ready to risk everything to care for
harry sirius is clearly near the top of
the list of the most important mentors
in harry's life number one albus
dumbledore an ever-present and
incredibly powerful magical figure
throughout the entire harry potter
series dumbledore is my number one pick
as harry's most influential and
impactful mentor albus starts off his
relationship with harry in the
philosopher's stone dropping words of
wisdom on him after his first encounter
with the dark lord such as it takes a
great deal of bravery to stand up to our
enemies but just as much to stand up to
our friends from there dumbledore
continues to guide and support harry as
the two build a relationship based on
albus's extensive wisdom harry's
willingness to learn and dumbledore's
knowledge that harry is the wizarding
world's only hope to defeat voldemort
although dumbledore was without a doubt
a huge influence in harry's life he
certainly was not the easiest mentor to
rely on often nowhere to be found and
showing up at times during inconvenient
moments like when harry was about to ask
a beautiful muggle on a date he was
certainly a frustrating mentor to say
the least but for every half-truth and
partial revelation he provided harry
with dumbledore also taught the boy a
lot of things he revealed past events
through the pensive a magical device
used to store and review memories and
took harry with him on a mission to
destroy a horcrux which harboured part
of voldemort's soul
he even mentored harry in the afterlife
helping him sort through the events that
led harry to king's cross station and
what he should do from there do i
believe that dumbledore should have been
more honest with harry about certain
things yes of course but does that
impact the fact that he was harry's
longest standing most influential mentor
no i don't believe it does and with that
we have come to the end of another video
what do you think did i miss any obvious
mentors do you agree with how i've
ranked these five let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel until next time i'm not
worried harry i'm with you
[Music]
you